[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
you behold your brother's case in
amazement
[Music]
i knew well you would
[Music]
pity you never paid a busted size heat
before
[Music]
now
behold how swiftly your brother swings
his sword
strike
rough
strike
but know that bearing a stolen ring
makes no half breeder king
soaked in my blood it will soon be
slightly off your arm like a serpent
your kingdom
will not last
[Music]
let this misty haunt your living nights
till a flaming vengeance gorgeous on
your death
strike
[Music]
strike
now
behold
he's here
he's here
father is here the kingman lady the king
your fake is set and you cannot
this kingdom will be yours
thank you father my king
[Music]
[Music]
i i will save you mother
i won't kill your fueller
why would this throw away to such a
hellish place
to find what was stolen from me and what
is that
the kingdom
you must choose between kindness for
your give
or hate for your enemies
your strength breaks man's bones
i have the calling to break their minds
and night by night we will carry out my
pledge of
want to thank you vengeance
i will save you brother
hmm
you